life in the mansion how dates really
work most days and fantasy suite are you
saying you were worried about being
intimate with Becca yeah we're taking
you behind the scenes of The Bachelor
it's time for roses and Rose a hi
everybody i'm lauren zima and things are
about to get whoo you guys I am here to
answer all of your questions about what
goes on behind the scenes on the
bachelor and bachelorette thank you for
all of your submissions so many
questions submitted I love questions and
comments and they really love when you
guys say things like love you Lauren
before your comments and questions
because I need that thanks Jerry Chevy
now also everybody our video next week
will be one several of you have been
asking for the biggest breakdowns ever
so please submit in the comments some of
your favorite breakdowns in show history
anyway so thank you all for all of me
behind the scenes things you wanted to
know I have been on the phone with
sources I have been tapping and typing
away to get the answers for you let's
dive in so first from Jerry Jerry's
first because of the kind comment Jerry
wants to know if the fantasy suites are
shot consecutively in three days does
the bachelor really go to the fantasy
suite with one girl right after the
other the very next night how is that
not awkward
it is so Jerry here's the thing it's all
about scheduling sometimes there are gap
days in between the fantasy suites and
sometimes they are back-to-back kind of
gross anyway Laura wants to know how
much contestants know about the dates
before they go on them like how do they
know how to dress if you're gonna be
bungee jumping off a building versus
swimming in a hot tub in the middle of a
field
how do you know what to wear the answer
is we see the moment when it's revealed
who will go on the date well sources
tell me that right after that the
producers basically just give
contestants
brief description of the date like not
revealing too much but just so they know
what to wear dress appropriately drink
every time I give a solid answer on this
video some are better than others Mary
wants to know if producers ever get
involved with preventing people from
being sent home Mary that's a tough call
because it's a question not everybody's
super willing to answer how involved is
production with decisions that the leads
make I will say that from what I've
heard from everyone at the end of the
day it's the leaves choice on who's
gonna stay and who's gonna go
no I'll DUP being said does the producer
talk to the lead
I mean sure advise them discuss with
them sure I can't guarantee on what
exactly is said I'm sure it varies
season to season but okay
I can't drink for that because that's
all I can say anyway Julie wants to know
if there is a specific order in which
the contestants first appear at the
mansion and how do they figure out what
their entrances and exits are gonna be
actually a lot of the time what we end
up seeing on TV is not the order that
people went in they added around you
know and switch things and move things
to make for a good episode and a lot of
people come up with the ideas for how
they're gonna enter whether it's by
playing a piano that's on wheels or
coming in on a horse or comment in a
minivan
hello cool right whatever a lot of
people come up with the ideas themselves
I think that producers sometimes are
part of the creative but you know what
it's a TV show
and what was everybody's favorite
mansion entrance that they've ever seen
let me know also this goes beyond the
mansion stuff like remember when Karen
had that bouncy house
Oh Kranz idea you know she wanted to do
that and they made it happen the magic
of television cheers to the producers
anyhoo oh now we're getting dirty Sophia
I love it Sophia wants to know whoa what
happens in the fantasy suite
just what goes on do they have sex lol
that's what she says
does the bachelor do it with both of the
contestants well Sofia three people
usually are in the fantasy suites
episodes but yes the answer is yes Ali
Fedotowsky said that a lot of people
sleep with each other and the fantasy
suites it does go down and Chris soules
told ET that there is often protection
provided in the fantasy suites that it's
on the nightstand so keeping it safe
that's great also the contestants have
to be screened for STDs before they can
ever be on the show
keeping it less sexual what also happens
in the fantasy suites is that they for
the first time gets some serious
off-camera time together so a lot of
important issues are hopefully discussed
Rachel Lindsay said she wanted to know
everything she had a list she wanted to
know you know what what was their credit
score like from these people got to get
those important questions answered in a
real way okay
Canon says what is on the list of what
they give you to ring how many suitcases
are you allowed just questions about
what to bring so I looked into this
everybody's allowed to bring two bags
one to Colton our new bachelor brought
in one of his bags an air-conditioner to
paradise he gave up a whole bag for a
portable air conditioner because he'd
heard it was so hot there so you can
largely put almost anything you want in
those bags but I have heard that you are
not supposed to bring and shouldn't even
bother to pack sunglasses and hats if
you guys have ever noticed during
filming you won't see people wearing
sunglasses and hats because they cover
your face so that's why they're always
sweating on the Sun just squinting to
that hot Mexican Sun yeah um also you're
not supposed to bring electronics
because know you can't be on your phone
anyway
[Music]
speaking of green yet wants to know if
people take breaks where they can be on
their phone no a lot of people do sneak
into phones from what I've heard some
people sneak him in but you're not
supposed to be on a phone and you often
get caught no phones allowed though Ben
Higgins did tell me that when he was in
a hotel once because when they're
traveling they start getting put up in
hotels
he found an iPad that was used to
control the features of the room and he
got on the Wi-Fi and he looked up his
final three women he said it didn't
affect his decision ultimately okay
Larissa wants to know how the producers
are able to get so close with the cast
good question Larissa they do get close
I will say a lot of people are skeptical
of these relationships between the
producers and the cast
but they have to be close to get people
to open up and talk about their feelings
I mean these contestants are thrust into
a world meeting all new people you got
to get close to get them to really talk
and dive in and be on the journey and be
vulnerable and part of how they do that
is that producers are specifically
assigned to certain cast members like
one producer will kind of be in charge
of 3ish cast members and then there's
one producer who specifically works with
the lead with the bachelor/bachelorette
and that's how they get close they spend
time together and develop a bond I'm not
drinking enough I need to be giving
myself more credit for answering these
questions so well
drink every time you think about the
fantasy suites man back to back that
would be a note for me would you guys be
okay with that if it was my fantasy
suite night I'd be like where you want
somebody else last night okay I gotta go
hey give me that see you tomorrow
nope it's just weird isn't it is that
just me then again you're on this show
in the first place so it's all weird dad
I did not downtown steel wants to know
I'm getting a you know what I will drink
every time I'd probably get a youtube
name wrong I'm sorry guys my youtube
name is just lauren zima everybody has
these creative youtube names like yeti
kitty what was it it's like your screen
name that's remember when people ask you
always your aims screaming when you're
in like high school
mine was drama queen and the year I was
born which I won't say well the only
reason I'm not saying the year that I
was born is not because I'm afraid of
telling you guys my age but because
sometimes I give a fake year when I'm
like signing up for things cuz I don't
want too much of my real information out
there so I have a fake year and a real
year and a fake birthday and a real
birthday I'm off the grid anyway so
steel magnolias yard
I don't know steel wants to know how do
the guys and girls spend their time in
the mansion if they are stripped of
phones and Internet are they just
socializing and drinking 24/7 yes that
part I'd be down with I've always said I
would I think want to go on the show
just to hang out in the mansion and like
drink and make some friends for a while
sounds fun so they are not allowed
phones they do not have access to the
news they are allowed to bring books to
a certain extent I believe I know that
religious books are allowed journaling
is allowed but you see it on the show
people do a lot of working out they do a
lot of eating food isn't made for them
the kitchen is filled but in the mansion
people make their own food so cooking
that is spend time on and swimming and
drinking and tannin absolutely
loudly would you guys like to be in the
mansion and do that or would you get
bored but now okay Brittany Brittany
wants to know when the interviews are
done during the dates they pull them
aside and interview them right there
that's why the dates takes so Laura is
wondering if contestants get their
phones back during hometowns and what
restrictions are there when they go home
no they don't get their phones back and
I called a couple people to find this
out you guys and they don't get to stay
with their families either they go back
to their hotels
so when here on your hometown it's kind
of weird but you are only talking to
your own family on camera you don't like
get a moment alone with them or anything
so it all happens on camera and then you
got to leave
you can't even sleep in your childhood
room with your NSYNC posters oh my K but
a banana bomb mom okay why do I keep
seeing that drink every time I sing that
stupid little mama Beach I like that
name wants to know how much time the
lead actually spends off-camera with the
contestant are they allowed to spend
time alone with them no not really
sometimes they make it happen Jojo and
Jordan actually just told us this we got
to hang out when I need in and out we do
it
off-camera we do get to do that I was
begging for it for weeks and we kind of
did our sour interviews after my
hometown at the same hotel I'm like come
on just like 30 minutes 30 minutes but
they really don't get along time
together before the fantasy suites know
they're not supposed to anyway
supposed to all be on camera juicy
moments what's here they pour tea on
moment it's a water pokemon see probably
jumping in the ocean
I've gone off on a tangent erin nicole
wants to know do they know who their top
two are pretty early on I mean I think
that's obvious from who is often there
in the end you know with pretty much
every recent Bachelorette the guy who
got her first impression rose ended up
being the guy she picked chemistry
matters our first connection matters
attraction matters and women have great
intuition should I listen to my
intuition more am I on my first night
thinking back got a couple regrets live
and learn
anyway um another person who I think's
YouTube name is vs1
Victoria's Secret one mm-hmm how do the
bachelors remember the names on the
first day is there a list the answer is
they don't if they go back and forth
saying a few names and then they go and
look at pictures then they come back and
sometimes people get it wrong Katie I'm
very embarrassed to tell you this Katie
I accidentally called out the wrong name
and Mooney ba' asks if the contestants
have to pack their bags before every
single rose ceremony yes they do and I'm
told they get very sick of packing you
guys those are so many behind-the-scenes
questions answered okay I feel like I
got more YouTube names wrong than I
acknowledged so I'm also gonna drink for
that and I'm just gonna drink for all
those contestants out there who had to
go back to back in the fantasy suites
sorry
and just cheers to you guys for giving
me all those great questions now I'm
just coming up with reasons to drink
okay now you guys had also been asking
about bachelor news you want a few
updates should oh so I am just going to
fire things off Shanny pottinger oh you
sound like a wizard Oh
Shanny pulling up wants to know I'm
become Dobby now Dobby the house-elf hey
Lauren could you please give us an
update on Becca M's pregnancy yes she's
three months from her due date and she
looks beautiful and she's happily still
with the father of the baby and she
seems great
Chantelle wants to know if clay and
Angela are still dating yes they post on
Instagram together quite a lot I think
they're very cute and seem like two nice
people they're doing a lot of traveling
to see each other that's important to
see each other in person how I've made
that mistake oh I'm so busy I don't have
time to see people Maureen had a
question well she says Lauren I'm not
ready to quit on wills Reed why is he
quiet where is he
I miss him he's around he's on Instagram
and he had recently posted an ad for
bumble so I think he's okay but your
concern is much appreciated and very
kind and you're not ready to quit him I
can't what is that front the whole
Brokeback Mountain I wish I knew how to
quit you I'm not ready to quit so
Green yet says hopefully next week you
can provide more details on the current
Colton spoilers next week how many next
week drink every time somebody said next
week so I am NOT into spoilers I don't
want to give them I think a lot of
people want to just watch the show as it
happens but I will just simply tell you
where filming is at right now I do know
that they wrapped filming
internationally they are now in the
phase of doing hometowns
so Colton's doing hometowns right now
and pretty soon they're gonna be filming
the finale so that's gonna happen and
then we will get Colton's season in
early January just the facts by the way
I would love to hear you guys's
predictions for what kind of woman you
think Colton will end up with knowing
what we know about him I mean he we
don't he did it Beca kufran we know he
dated that Aly Raisman the gymnast he
abouthe on his past dating history what
kind of woman do you think he will go
for and I'm predicting that they're
gonna have some versions on his season
it would just make sense so will he end
up with a fellow virgin what do you
think I'm intrigued
well Colton go back to back with people
the fantasy suite I don't know but I do
know one thing it's Halloween week guys
and JC unlike many people in this
franchise never disappoints JC please
come show us what you wore today in
black and orange for Halloween JC
everybody all right my friends so this
video was all about behind the scenes
questions and now you don't know he
doesn't know what I'm about to do but
I'm gonna grill you on some behind the
scenes JC questions because people love
you what are you looking for in a woman
integrity you know and it a lot of it
now is the inside I'm done with the
crazy he's done with the crazy he's
experienced and crazy what physical
attributes are you attracted to
now putting me on the spot at all I take
care of myself
I really do try to stay as healthy as
possible so I like to see that in kind
Wow wouldn't answer just health I love
it everybody behind the scenes with Jacy
he's available he did not know I was
gonna do that guys thank you so much for
watching as usual and thank you for your
patience last week we had a lot of tech
issues but Jacy pulled through and we
got that video up for you it's just a
little late next week's video is going
to be the best and by best I kind of
mean worst but in the best way
breakdowns ever so leave in the comments
your favorite breakdowns in history of
the show it can be a meltdown it can be
an emotional mess it can be a rant it
can be someone angry me somebody stormed
off the breakdowns when did it all go
alright okay thank you I love you all
happy Halloween week and let me know if
anybody dressed up as any bachelor folks
cuz that's always fun bye
[Music]
great hahahahaha
no Vlad yes nope we're getting you a
great date
[Laughter]